now in order to understand how we obtain
input from the user it's best
represented in a simple analogy
newspaper subscription for instance
newspapers are printed every day with a
rich set of data that I don't have
access to unless I willingly subscribe
to or receive that paper input handling
an HTML 5 is a lot like that in
JavaScript we have the ability to
subscribe to this input data such that
when an event occurs a block of code
will be called to get started with this
process you need to tell the browser
that you'd like to subscribe to a
certain event such as on click on Mouse
move or on key down alongside what
function you'd like to call when that
event happens let's take a look at the
code you can see here that we grab an
element from the Dom named P lubes for
life and add an event listener to it for
mouse move what occurs is that when the
mouse move event happens on the Dom
object the Mon Mouse move function will
be called where we've previously defined
on mouse move before this declaration